effectivement cotisé toute l'asie en
reste avec notre intervention était très
intéressante mais elle a strictement
rien à voir avec la question posée qui
et les pensions de réversion donc sujets
que vous connaissez pas qu'on sait mais
le problème des pensions est vite le
problème des pensions de réversion se
pose effectivement on a deux points
totalement différent premièrement on a
un système actuellement qui n'est pas
équitable parce que les pensions de
réversion sont différents pour le dock
pour le public pour le régime général et
pour les régimes complémentaires dont il
faut unifier le tour que ce soit la même
chose quel que soit le régime
et ensuite il faut affirmer que 1 les
pensions de réversion sont maintenus et
deuxièmement que le système reste comme
il est c'est à dire que les pensions de
réversion ne sont pas une pension
d'assistance que l'on donne aux plus
hauts peuvent les plus pauvres c'est un
droit acquis par les cotisations du
ménage et on peut il ya un certain
nombre de propositions nous on a proposé
de dire la pension de reversions dans
tous les régimes ça doit être égale aux
deux tiers de la pension du conjoint
décédé moins un tiers delà de ce que le
le conjoint survivant de manière à ce qu
effectivement lorsque le match est
généralement mari qui décède le premier
lorsque le mari décède le pouvoir
d'achat de la veuve ne soit pas trop
affectée et c'est trés rendent le par
contre la proposition de bruno le maire
est extrêmement dangereuse consistant à
dire ben on va faire un système qui est
centrée sur les les plus les très
pauvres et cette proposition avait déjà
été fait il ya une dizaine d'années et
ça a joué devant la mobilisation des
cadres cette refonte des aides sociales
vous l'avez dit s'inscrit dans un
objectif beaucoup plus large qui est la
réduction des dépenses publiques le
niveau des dépenses publiques s'est
élevé à 56 4% du pib en 2010 est ses 10
points de plus que la moyenne de l'union
européenne
la france s'est engagée auprès de
l'union européenne à réduire sa dépense
publique de 3 à 4 points du pib d'ici
2022 c'est à dire 75 à 100 milliards
d'euros
sa part est monumentale est ce que c'est
un objectif atteignable
jérôme bascher
en fait qu'est là encore il va y avoir
une belle arnaque c'est que au moment où
le président de la république a fait
cette promesse les dépenses publiques
n'était pas celle que l'on croyait et
celles qui se sont avérées en 2017
l est sont avérées à peu près être un
point et demi au dessus de ce qu'il
pensait et donc quand vous voulez
réduire de 3 ou 4 point à paraître c'est
pas ça assez revenir dans la moyenne
européenne
c'est ça l'idée maintenant on est bien
plus haut donc la marche est bien plus
difficile donc il ya là encore une
grande mystification sur les chiffres
mais ça en a pris l'habitude dans le
vrai sujet c'est comment on réduit la
dépense publique est aujourd'hui ce qui
est certain la cour des comptes l'a dit
l'union européenne l'a dit ceux qui ont
fait l'effort sur la dépense publique ce
sont à les collectivités locales
2 c'est que la sphère sociale celui qui
n'a pas fait d'effort c'est l'état
l'état propose aujourd'hui je sais que
nous en parlerons bientôt un contrat aux
collectivités locales d'augmentation de
la dépense publique de 1,2 pour cent là
où lui-même fait 2,7 pour cent sur son
propre but ils n'ont pas fait les bons
efforts donc ils vont chercher les
efforts ailleurs auprès des
collectivités auprès des pensions de
réversion auprès de la ss il y aura donc
plein de sujets de sujets sociaux qui
sont encore dans la sphère état sur
lesquels se posera la question
marina elle émane c'est cet objectif qui
nous pousse à parler au matin du défilé
dans aucun traité européen
au nom de quoi le gouvernement français
a décidé ça c'était une promesse de
campagne de manuel peut-être mais il
n'empêche qu'il a fait 24 pour son
premier tour et je ne crois pas que ceux
qui ont voté comme moi pour lui au
deuxième tour pour pas voir marine le
pen avel avait mandaté sur l'ensemble de
son programme deux aimants le tout pour
de dépenses publiques
il dépend du pib la première des choses
dont nous avons besoin dans ce pays
c'est d'avoir une croissance une
croissance qualitative
une croissance qui nous qui nous tire
vers l'avenir durable en termes de
respect de l'environnement et qui est
juste et durable oui ce que j'allais
vous dites est une politique juste
c'est-à-dire une croissance qui est
partagé et qui crée une dynamique
positive dans le pays
bon et la réduction des dépenses
publiques quand je vois par exemple que
la sécu a quasiment maintenant est à peu
près équilibré 1 on nous dit la première
toile etc
mais bon bientôt l équilibre et quand je
vois l'état d urgence l'état de
l'hôpital public jeudi que l' on a tiré
la corde trop loin et que l'obsession de
la dépense pour réduire la dépense est
absurde
de l'autre côté j'ai parlé toute une
série de recettes fiscales
je reste convaincu que les aides aux
entreprises et 41 milliards ces impacts
betc on aurait pu et on devrait encore
mieux le ciblées pour être sûr que ça va
être vraiment les secteurs qui ont
besoin de compétitivité ou qui peuvent
réellement tirer l'économie nationale
dont il ya il ya vraiment cette
obsession de la baisse des dépenses
publiques
elle est comparée à la moyenne
européenne je remis je suis pas d'accord
parce que quand vous avez l'école
publique mais quand on a les moliérois
ni ailleurs n'est pas publique et
qu'elle est privée quand vous avez les
assurances maladies qui sont payés ça
revient au même
en termes de blocage d'une partie des
richesses sur des dépenses ciblées et
saône et roanne six ans rester zen et à
droite je suis de gauche
ça c'est une différence j'ai aussi je
vais faire que je veux faire des amis
encore sur le banc d'en face mais en
plus fins et pas une question de droite
ou de gauche vous avez appartenu au
gouvernement mon candidat ya cinq ans
avait promis un déficit zéro pour
justement maîtriser les dépenses
publiques d'ici 2022 c'est thomas qui
dédient s'est lui surtout
malheureusement il n'y est pas arrivé
le problème allait pour ce public faut
juste répéter ou pas être compétitivité
ou paraître croissance on aura pas de
croissance tant qu'on ne diminuera pas
nos dépenses publiques ça c'est un fait
tous les pays européens justement qui
ont retrouvé la croissance en l'ont fait
parce que justement vont diminuer la
dépense publique qui dit d'espèces de la
dette baisse de la dépense publique dit
baisse justement des prélèvements
obligatoires donc diffa les fameux fonds
nous libère les fameuses énergies
cette baisse justement 7,9 c'est
important organisé s'est passé en italie
regarde ce qui se passe en angleterre
regarder ce qui se faisait l'écho le
blick
je sens que du contexte économique les
deux sont pas forcément liés
les deux sont pas forcément liés on vous
laisse finir erwan saison ce qui se
passe c'est que sur la dépense publique
le levier on voit bien des prestations
sociales va difficile justement réalisé
moi je suis d'accord avec monsieur
l'état doit faire sa part une chose
justement sur lesquels il peut fortement
agir c'est le nombre de fonctionnaires
le nombre d'emplois publics aujourd'hui
il ya 280 milliards justement d'euros
qui sont dépensés chaque année justement
masse salariale et on assure un
quinquennat 600000 personnes qui parlent
juste
la retraite le fait de ne pas remplacer
certains postes qu'on jugerait plus
pertinent parce que au cas où tous nous
le réveillons des revenus de révolution
numérique beaucoup beaucoup d'emplois
sont en train de disparaître je pense
aux postes de téléopérateurs
je pense au poste de guide agents de
guichet et c'est nous à l'institut
sapiens ont évalué que c'était environ
1,6 million d'emplois justement qui
n'était pas la peine de renouveler dans
les 20 prochaines années grâce à cette
révolution
on économise 60 milliards grâce à ça
aujourd'hui mettons ce débat là sur la
table et ça nous évitera de faire comme
le disait monsieur avant des coups de
rabot qui soit complètement inutile
parce qu'on va encore une fois coupée à
la marge et pas en profondeur en rythme
les dépenses publiques d'administration
en france sont équivalentes à celles des
autres pays de l'union européenne ce qui
nous caractérise c'est d'une part des
trains on a la bombe atomique et une
capacité d'intervention à l'extérieur ça
nous coûte de l'argent
on a deux enfants par femme eh ben ça
nous coûte de l'argent tu par rapport
aux pays qui ont 1,3 enfant trois
enfants par femme
on a un système de protection sociale
généreux en france les retraités ont le
même niveau de vie que les actifs en
suède
les retraités ont un niveau de vie 25 +
25 % plus bas que les actifs
on peut regarder voilà en france par
exemple on aide les maires qu'ils
arrêtent de travailler pour élever leurs
enfants et on aide aussi à la garde
d'enfants on a fait un choix qui est que
dans beaucoup de leu leu dans beaucoup
de domaines on a choisi effectivement
d'avoir un système public parce que
c'est un système solidaire et parce que
c'est qu'on regarde par exemple il
exauce du conflit c'est tout a été
adressé un dernier exemple ccc moins
coûteux doc la question qui se pose
c'est effectivement
quelles sont les dépenses publiques qui
sont utiles et celles qui le sont pas et
vous dire il ya des fonctionnaires
il ya trop de fonctionnaires nous sommes
d'accord mais y'a pas très d'enseignants
y'a pas assez d'infirmières ya passé et
les aides sociales on n'y touche pas on
a bien compris votre message merci
infiniment à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat dans un enfant
c'est le match des idées il va opposer
guillaume klossa à frédéric pons on va
évoquer les divisions européennes sur la
question migratoire
mini sommet d'hier est un échec le grand
sommet attendu en fin de semaine ne
s'annonce pas plus réussi et au sein
même de notre parlement la question
n'est pas moins polémique
le sénat a poursuivi aujourd'hui les
votes autour du texte asile immigration
et ce n'est pas tout à fait la ligne du
gouvernement c'est le point avec nelson
jetair certains parlent d'un
durcissement du texte
d'autres d'un véritable contre-projet
élaboré par la droite sénatoriale
discuté en séance depuis mardi dernier
la version sénat du projet de loi asile
et immigration porté par gérard collomb
n'en finit plus de créer la controverse
au sein de l'opposition
c'est un moment où on peut considérer
c'est l'objet de cette discussion c'est
la position du gouvernement qui est
défendue par la droite en allant plus
loin
parmi les mesures portées par la
majorité sénatoriale l'organisation d'un
débat annuel sur la gestion des flux
migratoires la limitation du
regroupement familial
le remplacement de l'aide médicale
d'état par une aide médicale d'urgence
ou encore la suppression de
l'assouplissement du délit de solidarité
vous ne pouvez pas avoir une immigration
régulière et un traitement de la ville
qu'ils soient faits dans de bonnes
conditions au profit de ceux qui doivent
en bénéficier
sinon on n'est pas capable d'avoir un
discours ferme à l'égard de ceux qui
viennent régulièrement sur le territoire
et qui veulent t restés dans l'hémicycle
les débats se prolongeront jusqu'au vote
solennel prévu demain après midi
un vote qui intervient dans un contexte
international pour le moins crispés sur
ce dossier avec nous pour ce match des
idées ce soir guillaume klossa fondateur
du think tank europanova initiateurs du
mouvement civique au europa frédéric
pons bonsoir avons également journaliste
écrivain spécialiste des questions
géopolitiques
votre dernier ouvrage poutine aux
éditions calmann lévy on le voit la
droite sénatoriale du cil durci le texte
asile immigration emmanuel macron
propose avec l'espagne des centres
fermés sur le sol européen pour les
migrants la france est en train de
durcir sa ligne sur la question
migratoire est ce que ça vous semble
être une solution à la crise que
traverse l'europe qui ont classe à je ne
sais pas si c'est une solution mais je
vois que tous les pays européens sont en
train de durcir leur ligne et je pense
que cela correspond à une évolution des
attentes inquiétudes des citoyens
européens et
donc il ya une sorte de cercle vicieux
qui est que les citoyens étant de plus
en plus inquiet les politiques et s'est
durci et puis à un phénomène particulier
en france c'est que il ya une tension
entre la république en marché et la
droite qui a besoin de se distinguer et
donc le débat au sénat on voit que la
ligne est de plus en plus sévères alors
que ces mêmes sénateurs et il ya encore
quelques mois aurait été beaucoup je
veux dire beaucoup plus beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins ferme et donc qu'il ya
une compétition inter où la droite veut
être plus à droite que la république en
marche
donc moi ce que je comprends c'est que
ça remplit des objectifs politiques mais
que cela ne règle pas le problème
loin de la ddt pour répondre aussi à la
première question on a assisté là un
réveil des peuples sur ce sujet là ces
dernières années on l'a vu en europe
centrale ur de l'est la pologne la
hongrie et les autres pays en italie en
autriche et les l'europe occidentale
doit tenir compte aussi deux salles ce
qu'on appelle lé vote populiste ont
clairement marqué une inquiétude une
méfiance parfois un rejet de cette
immigration clandestine
aujourd'hui on est un peu à contre temps
c'est-à-dire les propositions françaises
notamment d'installer des hotspots en
europe
c'est un peu aberrant ça ne réglera rien
n'oublions pas que le groupe de visegrad
c'est à dire la pologne et la hongrie
principalement on proposait des hotspots
ces fameux centre d'accueil de rétention
en afrique même il y a déjà quelques
années la hongrie a été le premier pays
à proposer ça aujourd'hui on se
rapproche de cette solution mais à tout
petits pas en fait un pas de côté un pas
en arrière un peu en avance et on ose
parler et on retarde la solution de
l'arrêt problème majeur attention parce
que d'abord il n'ya pas une crise
migratoire actuellement autant il y
avait une crise migratoire avec des pics
et plusieurs millions centaines de
milliers de migrants à la crise mais
parlons il ya une crise politique qui
prend un angle sur les migrations
mais on n'est pas face à des
déferlements de migrants tel qu'on peut
le lire dans la presse et par ailleurs
je pense qu'il faut distinguer migration
légale migration illégale et asile et ça
c'est très important
il ya une énorme confusion il ya une
énorme confusion sur les termes
la réalité c'est que partout dans le
monde parce que le monde n'est pas
stabilisée il ya des flux migratoires
considérable on a entre 40 et 60
millions que l'europe accueille une
toute petite partie de ces flux
migratoires et que partout dans le monde
on voit un rejet des migrants ça
concerne l'afrique du sud certains pays
africains
ça concerne même à certains égards les
états unis on voit qu'il ya des débats
au canada et donc il faut pas non plus
croire que c'est un problème franco
français et halo italien ou européens
non c'est un problème pardon pardon
pardon mais c'est un problème mondial
c'est il faut et c'est un problème qu'on
ne pourra résoudre qu'à l'échelle
mondiale avec une gouvernance mondiale
frédéric pongé vous laisser répond
j'aimerais juste que vous nous aidiez à
y voir clair dans ce qu'on appelle
effectivement la crise migratoire sur
regarde les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur justement va rectifier un
peu les choses de moins en moins de
migrants arrivent sur le sol européen
par la méditerranée on est passé de plus
d'un million 2015 on était au pic
effectivement à 172 1301 en 2017
alors cette crise migratoire réduit
encore maintenant est elle derrière nous
ou devant nous chacun a sa réponse je
propose d'écouter marine le pen puis
pierre moscovici puis bernard henri lévy
gouverner c'est prévoir et que nous
sommes au début du
migratoires nous ne sommes pas à la fin
de la crise migratoire le plus fort de
la crise migratoire où il ya derrière
nous c'est un fait il n'y a pas de crise
des migrants bleus
le solde migratoire comme disent les
démographes où les économistes nuls
fredrik mansson et comprend plus rien
les séquences avec bernard henri lévy
fait sourit enfin c'est il n'y a pas de
crise migratoire peut-être que vu du
rein d'un riad de marrakech il n'y a pas
de crise migratoire
en réalité même si ça a un peu décrue en
2010 est un peu on est passé d'un
million 2015 à 172 millions mais ces 172
milles pose un grave problème parce que
c'est l'avant garde d'une vague
migratoire qui ne peut que venir demain
en europe
quand on va en afrique c'est mon cas j'y
vais très souvent quand on va au maghreb
et en afrique subsaharienne
on a des millions de gens qui ne rêve
que d'une chose c'est de remonter vers
le nord de passer la méditerranée il y a
des difficultés
donc ça ralentit un peu le flux il y à
des politiques migratoires un peu plus
restrictives en europe mais ça n'empêche
pas que des dizaines de millions
d'africains notamment pour ne parler que
de l'afrique et là je parle pas de
l'asie sont prêts à tenter la grande
aventure sont prêts à économiser pendant
des années les villages se cotisent pour
envoyer des jeunes vers l'europe
dire qu'il n'ya pas de crise migratoire
sait prendre ses désirs pour des
réalités
mais ça ne ça ne repose sur rien peut
s'il n'y avait pas de crise migratoire
pourquoi on a ces mouvements populistes
dans toute l'europe qui sont en train de
se lever pour quoi il ya une crise
migratoire est en train de produire une
crise politique majeure en europe
si on veut n'estime qu'elle n'existe pas
cette crise nous ont faits attendez
attendez il faut pas tout mélanger il
n'y a pas ce qu'on appelle une crise
migratoire c'est à dire un pic avec des
déferlements de migrants aujourd'hui de
nom mais soyons précis pas insultant
pour les milliers de gens qui meurent en
méditerranée depuis des années par ici
c'est ici que ces gens là veulent venir
en europe et ces gens l'armée il ya
toujours une offre non mais au passage
et dire que ça n'existe mais bas mais
brand et qu'on mettait que vous donnez
moi
donnez moi c'est pas du tout ce que je
dis et j'admire votre art de déformer
mes propos
avec un talent énorme vous devenir ou
bien sûr qu'il y en a eu ni pardon je
dis qu'il ya une crise politique majeure
qui pour l'europe à partir des
migrations je dis qu'il ya un phénomène
migratoire global qui est problématique
à l'échelle du monde parce qu'il ya
entre 40 et 60 millions de personnes qui
veulent qu'ils qui veulent bouger chaque
année aujourd'hui l'europe est la région
du monde pardon mais vous pouvez me dire
le contraire qui en accueille le mois et
si vous avez des chiffres qui peuvent
prouver que c'est faux vous voulez dire
hey est de très loin le mois et donc
s'il ya une crise migratoire elle ne
concerne pas d'abord l'europe
en effet et il y à un mouvement
populiste pardonnez moi en effet il ya
une montée des populismes qu'on voit
depuis 20 ans et qui est continu et qui
n'avait pas comme première attache sauf
en france peut-être les l'émigration et
il y à un sujet aujourd'hui spécifique
avec l'italie qui refusent de d'assumer
ses responsabilités qui sont celle
d'accueillir des bateaux pour voir s'il
ya des gens qui ont le droit ou non à
l'asile et qui pose un problème
politique à tous les européens
maintenant l'europe a apporté une
réponse conjoncturelle qui a permis de
ralentir les flux elle n'a pas apporté
de réponses structurelles je crois que
le vrai défi et c'est le vrai défi des
manuels macron dans gala merkel et des
européens au prochain conseil à mon avis
au suivant une vraie réponse
structurelle par rapport à un défi vous
avez raison migratoire sur le long terme
pour l'europe qui est majeur mais pas
seulement pour l'europe mais là nous
nous sommes en europe vont concerner
directement ses portes de la chapelle et
et akalé que se situe des bidonvilles
nouveau qui n'existait pas il ya 20 ans
et qui concernent directement les
immigrés et que les populations autour
de français ou d'étrangers en situation
régulière qui vivent autour ne supporte
plus ça veut dire qu'il ya une crise que
et ça se traduit par des votes
si vous ne voulez pas le voir je suis
très inquiet pour nos enfants et nos
petits enfants en ce moment en afrique
je nie pas il ya des millions de gens
qui attendent de passer je voulais
non mais je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas à
ce sujet migratoires on est on est
d'accord en idées que je dis pas non
plus qu a pas un sujet d'identité qui
concerne tous les pays occidentaux et
toutes les démocraties avec la montée
des populismes même dans des pays où il
n'y a absolument pas d'immigration 1
vous le remarquerez parfois sanaa s'est
complètement déconnecté et pour moi le
sujet de fond c'est que nous avons été
élevés nous européens et occidentaux
dans un monde que nous dominions et
aujourd'hui nous ne dominons plus et
plus nos valeurs qui prime à partir de
là ça plus des phénomènes qui inquiète
et le sujet migratoires et la crise
potentielle dont vous parlez avec est un
sujet qu'il faut qu'il faut traiter et
c'est pour ça qu est-ce qui vous mais
moi oui mais sauf que on n'est pas
d'accord sur cela qu est ce qu il
convient maintenant est ce qu'il faut
faire donc c'est un jeune qui voudrait
partenariat un jeu il faut prendre à
rêver je suis sur le plan médiatique
mais je suis tout à fait d'accord pays
joue un rôle très important lien avec
l'afrique un pays joue un rôle
stratégique dans cette crise migratoire
c'est la turquie qui vient de réélire
air doan victoire au premier tour sur
fond d'accusations et de pression de
fraudes en tous genres peu voire pas de
réaction france si ce n'est celle de
jean-baptiste lemoyne le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des affaires
étrangères qui était l invité de public
sénat ce matin
la france et la turquie deux grandes
nations doivent continuer à avoir un
dialogue danse francs sur beaucoup de
sujets nous ça il ya un partenariat
stratégique qui existe entre entre
l'union européenne la turquie et donc
l'idée c'est naturellement de pouvoir
aussi faire face et bien en commun un
certain nombre de sujets dont le sujet
migratoires on le sait la turquie jour
où la nature est bon ils vont devoir
travailler ensemble mais c'est pas de
gaîté de coeur
guillaume klossa c'est pas le meilleur
interlocuteur possible pour emmanuel
macron c'est pas de gaîté de coeur et en
même temps emmanuel macron est un
réaliste est un pragmatique et il sait
que l'europe traite avec erdogan et
qu'il aura à traiter avec lui tu es au
moins avec erdogan
on sait une chose c'est qu'on sait
comment comment comment ils marchent
maintenant
non mais il a une parole et on sait
négocier avec lui moi je préférais un
démocrate à la tête et je pense que
manuel macron aussi à la tête de la
turquie on a vu que erdogan a été élu à
52 lui pensait il ya quelques mois être
élu à 60 ou 70
c'est pas un raz-de-marée en faveur mais
c'est l'homme fort de la turquie il est
légitime et on n'a d'autre choix que de
travailler avec lui et une turquie qui
est de moins en moins européenne ou pro
européenne devrait beaucoup entendre ces
propos de la part du qatar d'état de la
part d'une partie de la classe médiatico
politique sur poutine c'est exactement
la même chose
nous avons intérêt à travailler avec le
turc erdogan nous avons intérêt à
travailler avec l'adie mur poutine
entretuer ruth retenir une relation
politique pas forcément amicale mais
politique c'est ce que les états avaient
ratissé les sanctions est ce que ce
n'est pas tout à fait une relation
apaisée avec la russie là encore avec la
turquie qui occupe la partie nord de
chypre depuis 1974
on a accepté beaucoup de choses et bien
la russie a annexé la crimée qui est une
terre russe
on pourrait aussi un peu oublier ça et
reprendre des relations politiques
sérieuses et commerciales avec la russie
c'est ce vers quoi nous irons un jour
j'en suis persuadé mais en ce moment il
y a erdogan acceptable et un putin
détestable c'est un peu aberrant comme
position je pense que on n'est pas face
à un putin détestable on est face à un
rapport de force la russie respecte les
rapports de force il faut que les
européens
saches imposer le leur et à partir de là
on pourra travailler correctement avec
le 10 mai routine sur air doan ce matin
sur france info une écrivaine franco
turc a tenté d'expliquer pourquoi une
partie des turcs avaient effectivement
est votée ardoines et soutenir douanes
elle nous dit ceci il a donné au peuple
turc eu des meilleures conditions
économiques mais surtout il leur a donné
leur fierté
il a redonné une sorte de fierté de leur
religion il aura donné aussi un orgueil
de leur grand passé ottoman guillaume
klossa qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
je pense que là la raison il il a su se
réinscrire dans l'histoire longue de la
la la turquie et l'histoire aussi deux
des hommes forts turc il y avait une
attente il y avait une attente d'autant
plus grande que ses prédécesseurs
n'avait pas été enfin il y avait
beaucoup de scandales de corruption
et ça a beaucoup fragilisé la démocratie
en turquie notamment et notamment le
parti le parti kémaliste et je pense que
si le parti kémaliste avait été
exemplaire
erdogan n'aurait jamais été élu
président de l'as de la turquie donc il
y avait un vrai problème de défaillance
de des partis politiques
reid analyse avec la russie de poutine
réélu aussi c'est que ces hommes forts
autoritaire redonne confiance à leur
peuple donne de la fierté stabilise
l'économiste estaminet de pression mais
le christ ce sont les droits de vote et
même si ça nous déplaît à nous ce sont
les turcs qui ont voté ce sont les
hongrois qui ont élu sorbonne les russes
quand il est poutine pour qui la turquie
pensez vous y croyez s'il était candidat
réellement au fond d'eux mêmes
il aurait abandonné chypre qui est un
facteur bloquant depuis 1974 dans leur
marche vers l'europe
ils sont candidats à l'europe pour
exercer un certain chantage sur l'europe
mais ils ne sont pas réellement
candidats entrés dans l'union européenne
ils en connaissent trop les contraintes
et par rapport à leur régime et à leur
rêve impérial
ils savent que c'est incompatible il
reste qu'à savoir je crois qu erdogan ne
croit plus à l'intégration européenne
mais il faut quand même regarder le
résultat de ces élections
il n'y a que 50 pour 2 % des turcs alors
on peut dire que c'est considérable
qu'il est qui ont voté pour lui
alors qu'ils s'attendaient initialement
à 60 70 % il ya une vraie opposition et
il ya eu une vraie campagne démocratique
des gens de qualité qui sont menacés en
turquie fonctionnent d'une certaine
façon d'une certaine façon mais sûrement
pas satisfaisant c'est la fin de ce
match des idées c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à tous les deux dit avoir
participé on se retrouve demain la même
heure sur public sénat l'invité du
territoire d'infos demain c'est marc
philippe daubresse sénateurs à l'ère du
nord très bonne soirée rester au coeur
du débat
[Musique]
à
demain dans territoire d'infos marc
philippe daubresse sénateur du nord sera
l'invité de public sénat et de la presse
quotidienne régionale territoire d'infos
présenté par cyril viguier
demain à 8 heures en direct sur public
sénat tarde du gouvernement parmi des
inconnus les débuts de nicolas hulot
suscité des espoirs et déjà quelques
interrogations qui depuis n'ont pas
cessé d interrogations sur notre dame
des landes qui aurait pu être sa
victoire des interrogations aussi sur le
dossier du glyphosate où il a donné
l'impression d'avaler des couleuvres
cette semaine des as bio en tout bien
tout honneur à ministre en proie au
doute
déshabillons-les demain 23 heures sur
public sénat
[Musique]
ça vous regarde présentée par arnaud
ardoin dans un instant aucune femme ne
recourt de gaieté de coeur à
l'avortement
il suffit d'écouter les femmes c'est
toujours un drame
cela restera toujours un drame je crois
qu'il n'ya jamais dû y avoir à
l'assemblée un débat aussi houleux et
aussi diffamatoire
en quoi simone veil est elle réellement
une femme hors du commun on cherche à
comprendre avec la biographe ça à briand
la députée olivia grégoire et les
journalistes robert namias et michèle
cotta droit de suite présenté par
jean-pierre gratien ce soir à 20h30
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
dans ça vous regarde c'est votre débat
chaque soir en direct vous connaissez
notre rendez-vous 19h30 en direct 23h30
ou à revoir sur notre site lcp point fr
on parle ce soir des migrants au coeur
d'une crise sans précédent vous sonnez
qui lie la crise de la dette la crise
financière qui a touché de plein fouet
la grèce et une autre crise majeure et
importante qui frappe de plein fouet
l'europe et qui la divise on va revenir
bien sûr sur les divisions des pays
européens ils sont réunis hier d'une
manière informelle tous les pays
n'étaient pas présents mais le 28 et le
29 ils seront tous là pour tenter de
trouver une issue à cette crise vous
avez vu ce bateau l'aquarius mis en est
un autre qui est aujourd'hui au large de
malte qui ne pourra pas et bien accoster
sur les côtes italiennes parce que les
italiens ne le souhaite pas on va
revenir évidemment sur ces migrants ce
sont des femmes des hommes mais aussi
des enfants parce que sur ce bateau
récent il ya quatre bébés sur le sur le
bateau on va parler du bras fer
politique parce qu'il ya un véritable
bras de fer politique notamment entre le
président français le ministre matteo
salvini donc entre la france et l'italie
et il ya une crise interne en allemagne
entre landes gala merkel et la cdo et
puis un débat très philosophique sur la
manière dont l'europe doit accueillir
ces migrants ces personnes qui ont
traversé pour certains la moitié du
monde
on va faire le point ce soir il ya
plusieurs options sur la table des
centres extraterritoriaux hors de
l'union européenne
des centres au sein de l'union
européenne on va essayer de faire le
point évidemment sur les propositions
qui sont sur la table et puis matteo
salvini était d'ailleurs en libye pour
tenter de créer comme l'avait dit
emmanuel macron il ya quelques mois des
hotspots des centres d la libye certains
parlent même du niger pour créer ces
centres d'accueil sur les lieux de
transit ont fait le point ce soir lcp
point fr le jdd notre partenaire je vous
présente mes invités sophie auconie
bonsoir ce député udi agir indépendant
vous y mettez beaucoup de d'indre et
loire
elle ferait beau département et
auparavant vous étiez députée européenne
avec carrière avec karima delli que vous
nous présentez donc directement bon soir
karima delli députée européenne europe
écologie
r vous êtes en lice comme on dit pour
être tête de liste à ces prochaines
élections européennes en 2019 tout ça
n'est pas tranchée mais en tout cas vous
êtes candidate très investi sur ces
questions européennes sur cette question
des migrants vous écoutera dans quelques
instants jenlain la capelle bonsoir soit
vous êtes vice président du groupe et
rennes rassemblement national qui n'est
pas une route et rennes 1 c'est un
rassemblement national merci des travées
voulons c'est un boulevard on vous
écoutera parce que marine le pen a pris
la parole et vous êtes membre du conseil
régional merci d'être là
meriane ben le look arabo bonsoir un
professeur ou là le droit rien que le
droit avec vous ce soir professeur de
droit à l'université de nanterre
spécialiste du droit européen et des
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et on parlera des règles de
dublin parce qu'on utilise cette
expression est ce que cette règle dublin
est aujourd'hui remise en question
est-ce qu'il faut réinventer un nouveau
dispositif
on va faire le point dans quelques
instants mais d'abord retour évidemment
sur cette crise des migrants alors elle
ne dure pas depuis quelques semaines
elle dure depuis des mois pour ne pas
dire des années mais évidemment elle
s'est amplifiée avec l'arrivée au
pouvoir est bien de matteo salvini et
des hommes de la ligue qui ont
évidemment amplifié cette crise qui
refuse depuis quelques semaines et bien
d'accueillir ces bateaux leur
interdisant d'accoster sur les côtes
italiennes retour sur cette crise et
explications avec sophie des chiens
derrière l'apparenté camaraderie le bras
de fer a continué hier entre emmanuel
macron et son homologue italien giuseppe
compter farouchement opposés sur la
question migratoire
j'ai la france n'a d'ailleurs de leçon à
recevoir de personne nous sommes le
deuxième pays d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile
cette année et c'est dans cet esprit
pour ma part que je veux avancer pour
avancer et emmanuel macron sait qu'il
peut compter sur l'allemagne et
l'espagne face à l'italie qui partagent
une politique très populiste avec la
hongrie la pologne la république tchèque
et la slovaquie 4 pays rappelé à l'ordre
hier pour avoir décidé de boycotter ce
mini sommet européen
nous avons des valeurs c'est ce qui nous
a fait et à chaque fois que nous les
avons trahi
nous avons créé le pire les valeurs de
l'europe c'est le respect des droits de
l'homme et des droits des individus
c'est le respect des autres états et de
leur intégrité
et c'est cette solidarité qui nous tient
très contestée par l'ailé droite de sa
coalition sur la question migratoire
anguila merkel a voulu avancer
prudemment en proposant des accords bi
ou tri latéraux entre pays membres dans
la mesure du possible nous cherchons à
trouver des solutions européennes
et lorsque ce n'est pas possible nous
voulons rassembler ceux qui partagent un
même objectif et développer un cadre
d'action commun il reste encore du
travail avant le conseil européen à 28
qui se tiendra jeudi et vendredi
seul point d'entente trouvé hier le
renfort des frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne je m'adresse aux
politiques et puis évident le professeur
de droit sur le plateau va nous éclairer
mais une question toute simple avec ses
coups de menton côté français côté
italien le président français explique
qu'il n'a pas de leçons à recevoir
est-ce qu'il faut que l'italie il faut
obliger l'italie à recevoir ce ce bateau
chargé de 239 passagers dont je disais
des femmes des enfants et que l'italie
doit accepter d'une manière obligatoire
d'accueillir ce bateau moi je pense que
pour l'italie il
le fond et la forme la forme c'est qu'il
n'était pas acceptable d'entendre ce que
communique le ministre de l'intérieur
est objectivement ça n'est pas
acceptable parce qu'on a affaire à des
drames humains de véritables difficultés
pour ces hommes et ces femmes qui
prennent des risques pour traverser vous
disais tout à l'heure
ddd mère entière bref on ne peut pas
considérer ces migrants comme il l'a
fait ces jours derniers se dire qu'ils
ont de chair humaine dit salars ceci dit
il y a le fond et le fond c'est que 700
mille migrants sont arrivés en italie
depuis 2013 et que ça s'est fait dans un
mutisme total
et qu'à ce niveau là l'union européenne
est à mon niveau est à mon avis
responsable alors les états n'ont pas
donné la compétence à l'union européenne
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes dans cette difficulté
pour autant cette problématique là ne
peut être qu'européenne parce qu'on voit
que ça concerne might ça concerne donc
on oblige on oblige il a respecté les
règles non je pense qu'il faut qu'on
regarde ça d'un point de vue européen
avec effectivement des quotas avec un
certain nombre de deux remises en cause
de dublin dublin en ampleur mais dublin
3 qui à mon avis n'est donc les règles
européennes ne sont plus adaptées non il
faut que le que l'europe s'empare et
incarne cette politique de l'immigration
partant du principe qu aujourd'hui le
modèle européen ne corée était passé à
la conjoncture karima delli ses 650 me
theiss que di matteo salvini six ans à
4000 débarquement en quatre ans quatre
cent trente mille demandes d'asile
présentées en italie 170000 c'est
toujours lui qui le dit réfugié présumé
hébergés à la date d'aujourd'hui dans
des hôtels casernes et appartements pour
un montant supérieur à 5 milliards
d'euros c'est ce que di matteo salvini
dit de manière très factuelle voilà ce
que nous avons fait en matière de
d'accueil des réfugiés ou des migrants
est ce que vous dites vous députée
européenne qu'il faut obliger les
italiens selon les règles européennes à
accueillir ce bateau si on respectait
les règles européennes c'est à dire que
tous les états membres doit respecter
l'ensemble des règles c'est à dire tous
les états européens on
doivent respecter des directives
européennes sur l'accueil des réfugiés
sur la protection de ces humains ce
qu'on les traite souvent comme des
objets sont des humains et on voit bien
que c'est les égoïsmes nationaux qui
prime sur justement la conception de
l'europe c'est la prière la deuxième
chose l'europe n'a pas bien fait et
notamment la commission européenne n'a
pas bien fait de partir de 2015
elle présente un plan et elle dit par
répartition il faudra accueillir 150
mille personnes qu'est-ce qui se passe à
ce moment là à 2015 en 2004 la france
s'engage elle dit van mil ensuite on a
plein de pays qui refusent cependant
moins trente mille ans pour être précis
530000 je rassure tout le monde
trente mille c'est vraiment une goutte
d'eau ça représente 0 005 % de notre
population sait rien quand on regarde
pariant ce qui se passe au liban ou au
liban c'est que les flux migratoires en
italie ces 650 milles oui comment free
mais pourquoi ce large et ernie
chiffrage je termine pourquoi parce que
c'est ce règlement de dublin qui induit
le traitement du droit d'asile sur le
pays d'entrée et c'est par les côtes
dans maladresse et l'italie hills où les
migrants arrivent tôt je crois que les
ce qui a débouché le mini-sommet stade
salade bouger sur rien débout sur deux
conclusions le cynisme des états
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont peur notamment
au lieu de confondre d'affronter les les
les problèmes et leur prendre leurs
responsabilités quand ils s'en vont ils
sont complètement déstabilisée par quoi
déstabiliser par les questions de
sondage notamment par les voies les
populistes et de l'extrême droite
maintenant il faut siffler la fin de la
récré parce que ça va continuer et qu'il
faut trouver un véritable plan la
première chose il faut vraiment me
remettre à plat moi je le dis il faut
virer le règlement de dublin
elle se réveille marche je démens que ça
dure avant même large et d'un italien
quelle ligne sur quelles lignes vous
êtes au rassemblement national parce que
c'est vrai que il ya la fois un débat
humain sur le ces hommes ces femmes qui
qui qui traverse la frime et il les gens
ont des droits aussi il faut faire
attention qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'eux
parce que le bateau fait des ronds dans
l'eau le deuxième bateau attend de
savoir où il va
accueillis on se souvient de la france
qui avait été très silencieuse pour la
cua regus quand même oui parfaitement
qualifié leurs hôtes introduction
l'europe où l'union européenne dans ta
ville une crise majeure
une crise politique une crise migratoire
et c'est la responsable c'est la folle
politique immigrationniste qui depuis
des années est imposé aux nations
européennes qui valent aujourd'hui
retrouver leur liberté
vous y êtes priés patron est donc un
certain nombre de pays pas du tout a
sans doute payé aujourd'hui se soulèvent
donc on le voit l'italie avec matteo
salvini l'autriche
même le ministre l'intérieur d'angela
merkel en allemagne aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs solidarise mais également des
pays dans les pays de l'est ou lisez la
slovénie la hongrie la pologne et
l'autriche les tchèques se soit
l'autriche exactement à 102 pays
aujourd'hui se liguent et veulent
retrouver leur liberté et dix ans nous
n'avons plus les moyens d'accueillir
aujourd'hui les migrants alors on les
appelait les migrants ça reste toujours
très affectueux moi je le continuel et
zapper les clandestins appelons un chat
un chat sur les clandestins sont des
gens qui aujourd'hui ce sont des gens
qui non madame ce sont des gens
d'aujourd'hui viennent chez vous sans en
avoir le droit qui sont tombées sur le
territoire de manière illégale
et si nous avions la capacité financière
et si nous avions la possibilité
deviennent amants de tendre les bras et
les mains à ces gens-là nous le ferions
nous pompent le faire en france nous
avons neuf millions de porcs 9 millions
de gens qui vivent avec moins de 1000
euros par mois je crois que ça atteint
des lumières et aujourd'hui il y à
d'autres pour la mort d'autres solutions
alternatives on parlera mais je crois
qu'il faut qu'il y ait d'autres pays et
je vous aime la rue qui les accueillent
pourquoi pas l'algérie
pourquoi pas la tunisie jusqu'à ce chien
mais hier la route de l'état laïc
oui mais coûter la vie la france étant
aussi en difficulté eric ella 9 millions
fort et la philosophie me permets de
droit c'est insupportable la concurrence
des misères je vous le dis tout de suite
de dire faut d'abord s'occuper de nous
pauvres pour s'occuper des autres
c'est insupportable la france est la
sixième puissance mondiale
ça veut dire du fonctionnement du 2 mai
on est là on est une puissance mondiale
la question n'est pas de savoir pourquoi
ya de la pauvreté en france il faut
regarder ce qui s'est passé durant les
30 les 15 dernières années en france
c'est pour ça qu'on a de la pauvre des
maisons qui n'avaient qui n'a pas alors
de mettre maintenant la question
d'immigrants je vais vous dire ça
ça m'a absolument pas question
financière pour deux choses la première
c'est que l'union européenne a dépensé
notamment 13 milliards d'euros 13 pour m
justement la politique répressive
est-ce que ça a marché ça n'a pas me
dire quoi c'est schengen c'est
l'organisation bien glauque et nous nos
frontières de lyon voit bien que 13
milliards d'euros on peut faire autre
chose notamment des politiques
d'intégration sur nos territoires
on accueille tout le monde car i mode
comme la france notamment
non mais alors vous n'allez pas me
parler non mais vous allez pas me parler
de de l'argent des français avec moi
parce que le front national s'y rendent
déjà les 300000 gens venus de plus loin
comme vous voulez les déjà si vous
saviez données des trois cent mille
euros des assistants parlementaires
parce que ça aussi il faut le dire c'est
l'argent des français dont vous avez les
fortifs mais je ferme la parenthèse mais
jamais rien de différence entre réfugiés
entre réfugiés mais je vais légué leur
destin et immigrés immigrés moi je veux
pas parler de camp des saints y adhérer
comme si le terme les migrants les
migrants sont des hommes et des femmes
qui sont issus de territoire et qui
migrent pour des raisons économiques
est ce la présidente fait que le prison
macron ne veut pas sous des noms mais il
faut qu'on les aide qu'on les aide à se
développer alors que le plus implanté
mais on a des réfugiés politiques qui
eux sont en danger dans leur pays qui
vivent des choses que ses droits et s'il
est là c'est le droit d'asile et là
dessus aujourd'hui il faut conjuguer
le look arabe ou juste parce que vous
êtes professeur de droit je leur dit
merci qui démarre évidemment sur des
enjeux politiques sur les ans je dirais
humanitaire qu'est ce que dit le droit
sur le plan de cette question de la
migration de l'accueil des réfugiés
qu'est ce qu'il dit alors merci de me
donner la parole la visite mais vous
l'avez essayé bien sûr je lai et c'est
très intéressant pour moi d'être dans
une arène politique ça me change de mes
étudiants qui généralement m'écoute
assez religieusement dont vous écoutant
là où je dois m'imposer mais y'a pas de
problème je vais tout à fait le faire
alors d'abord c'est assez étrange de
voir comment le débat par il part au
tout de suite sur ben alors soit aux
gens tant on n'a pas assez d'europe
il faut que l'europe agisse l'europe
n'est pas à la hauteur etc soit au
contraire il ya vraiment trop d'europe
c'est pas possible c'est à cause de
l'europe que nous avons abouti à cette
situation catastrophique à cette
politique migratoire totalement délétère
à l'ouverture de nos frontières - tu
sais tu as donc c'est un petit peu
contradictoire déjà ça veut bien dire
que d'une manière ou d'une autre il ya
un problème dans le débat parce qu'on
peut pas à la fois être dans le trop
d'europe et dans le passé c'est que
nécessairement ya là et c'est évident
bien sûr une manière de de prendre des
arguments juridiques et prendre une
construction juridique qui est l'union
européenne et d'en faire et c'est tout à
fait normal
un enjeu politique majeur parce que bien
entendu c'est aussi une construction
politique et c'est un enjeu politique
majeur mais comme vous l'avez très bien
dit dès le départ s'il y a un temps si
fication de la crise maintenant ceux du
thalys et l'italie etc sur des
considérations strictement politique
c'est parce que nous avons un nouveau
gouvernement en italie qui a décidé de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu alors que
la situation migratoire par elle même
n'a pas nécessairement bulls éducation
depuis quinze jours donc c'est que
nécessairement ya là une réalité
politique de même qu'en allemagne c'est
très clairement parce qu angela merkel
est aujourd'hui en difficulté dans sa
coalition
et pourquoi elle l'est elle l'est parce
que la cs où elles mêmes cherchent à
récolter des voix c'est clair net et
précis que veulent parce qu'elle même
quand les prochaines élections
régionales elle va être en difficulté
mise en difficulté par l'extrême rang et
qu'en 2015 l'allemagne
r grand voyage avec seiko donc oui oui
mais la très précisément la cs ou fait
cette surenchère
parce qu'elle cherche aussi à se
positionner par rapport à l'électorat de
l'extrême droite c'est clair net et
précis je peux vous montrer juste un
sondage je joue beaucoup pour regarder
c'est intéressant parce que c'est le
regard des français non c'est pas les
politiques sont des français qui il nous
faut partager à travers ce sondage leur
rapport à cette question 42% des
français sont favorables à ce que les
migrants qui arrivent sur les côtes
grecques et italiennes soient répartis
dans les différents pays d'europe dans
la france contre 32% en avril 2015 donc
ça c'est une idée qui a germé ce
week-end et dont on parlera le 28 et le
29 et 58% des français sont opposés à
l'arrivée en france de ces migrants et
puis regardez sur le débat de l'aquarius
parce que c'était le plus plus récent 67
% de ces personnes interrogées bien
pense que l'aquarius transportant à son
bord 600 migrants ne devait pas être
accueilli en france le fn parmi les
personnes interrogées étaient 95 93 %
les républicains 84 les répudier la
république en marche à 58 la france
insoumise à 51% une majorité de ses
militants je note donc qui a une
majorité large mary rose et vert ni
consommer juste pour rebondir quand même
ce que vous disiez madame non mais il y
avait en face il y aura deux europe il y
à une union européenne aujourd'hui tel
quel et qu'on souhaite à bruxelles tient
impose des quotas de migrants par
exemple et qui impose sa politique que
soyez d'accord ou pas d'accord monsieur
macron d'ailleurs manière un peu
arrogant times manière je n'ai pas
exactement et se permet en plus de dire
et de proposer deux cent mille euros
damende par migrants n'ont accueilli
dans les pays mûrs ben moi je ça
scandaleux
ce coup de force deuxièmement il ya des
gens qui sont pour une europe différente
et nous on partira sans national de ces
gens là où ce blu une grande europe une
europe une europe des nations dont sort
d'une grande nation garde sa
souveraineté si son identité et kirkouk
comment voilà comment karim a du bon est
ce que la france parce que la question
est posée aux français à travers les
sondages mais ce que la france a
réellement plier vous évoquez 2015 on se
souvient la petite phrase de l'un de
laval ici dans l'émission on ne pourra
pas accueillir plus de 29 mille réfugiés
savait susciter le débat est ce que la
france a vraiment pris sa part parce que
le
à force pommerat de fer politique entre
l'italie la france porte là dessus
messali indices mais regardez vous êtes
très égoïste vous la france
on a fait le on a fait le boulot ou pas
franchement ce chiot connu j'espère
qu'on a des leçons à donner